continúa la búsqueda de los cuatro
menores desaparecidos en la selva de
Colombia luego de que se estrellara el
avión en El que viajaba en el Primero de
Mayo
los rastrillajes encontraron lo que
parecen ser señales positivas luego de
hallar elementos desperdigados como la
tapa de un biberón una zapatilla pequeña
un paniel usado y un refugio improvisado
se inician los registros desde esta
primer evidencia de la aeronave a los
360 grados en el cual aproximadamente al
noroccidente
420 metros una mujer de la comunidad
evidenció sobre el terreno una tapa de
color rosado y un marco de un celular de
color negro y lo más especial un pañal
utilizado que de acuerdo a la talla
puede ser de nuestro bebé de 11 meses
Christie sin embargo los miembros de la
operación entienden que el tiempo les
podría estar cobrando factura a los
menores lo que han dicho nuestro mayor
es también es que cada día que pasan los
niños se van agotando se van agotando
Eso quiere decir que cada hora cada
instante cada día es un tiempo precioso
para nosotros por eso estamos aquí con
el ejercicio de la minga espiritual la
minga territorial para mirar cómo
avanzamos en este propósito
decenas de militares apoyado por
voluntarios de las comunidades indígenas
cercanas e instituciones civiles y
estatales forman parte de la búsqueda de
estos niños de cuatro nueve y 11 años y
que cargan un bebé de 11 meses y se
abren las interrogantes algunos piensan
que de seguir vivos los menores Podrían
haber sido encontrados por grupos
autóctonos no detectados y estarían Bajo
su cuidado